one guy one of the all-time greats at
the running back position is very
interested in signing on for the
possibility of capping his career with a
ring here's adrian peterson when asked
if he would join the tampa bay
buccaneers
that would definitely be something that
i would be interested in playing with
tom brady
that by itself
you know is enticing um but having a
relationship with bruce harrions
um you know i don't know what they're
gonna have going you know for next
season but
if i'm a part of it if i if they want me
to be a part of it i'll be a part of it
for sure because i'm definitely trying
to
add a trophy to my my resume
leonard fournette do to become a free
agent they've got ronald jones still
under contract lesean mccoy
presumably just did a one-year deal i'm
pretty sure he just didn't want to deal
you know he's he's got back-to-back
back and didn't play in either game
at least he was active for this super
bowl last year he was not active he
really kind of fell out of favor it's
the second straight year the chiefs had
a veteran running back that they
ultimately realized what are we doing
with this guy right but two straight
years super bowl championship now
mds wrote something leading into the
super bowl about how sean mccoy's been a
non-factor for the buccaneers and
actually leonard fournette reacted to
that saying he's not an odd factor he's
helping us out in practice and stuff
well that's fine that's not our point
our point is during games he's not doing
anything but you know it helps to have
that veteran presence around no matter
what he may or may not be doing yeah and
the thing is the thing is
you're not going to have adrian peterson
if he gets a spot with the buccaneers
and they are in a position to do well
he's not going to be grousing about his
role how much he touches the football
right that's you you're signing on to be
part of something special and you accept
whatever your role is that's exactly
right you you've signed on winning was
the number one thing and we're already
good without you so we don't need
anybody or ev right at that point so uh
mike you made this point early on and
it's you know outstanding i mean i i
think there's gonna be a lot of guys in
this class as far as you know guys
towards the end of their career
uh whether they'll do it for a bargain
or what league minimum or whatever but
yeah they're going to look to wait let's
go down to tampa florida and can they
use me as some sort of role you know on
the football team there is value with
guys like adrian peterson and that i
don't know if you want to have him be
your number two guy
like to me
it's more where hey he has value
certainly but i think he's more of like
almost a number three at this point of
his career to where yeah he plays in
certain situations a guy's back our
backup or one of our other guys banged
up so now he gets in the rotation but
really you keep him there almost like an
insurance policy too that's like what
deshawn mccoy was it's just a guy where
tom brady and bruce arians go man if
they get hurt at least we know this guy
knows what to do he's played a lot of
football he'll pick up the blitzes he
won't mess things up and lose us the
game and that's where those kind of
veterans have great value on our roster
you know another guy that i'd thought of
a couple of times this week during the
show but there was never a chance to
mention him as it relates to chris
godwin possibly leaving
wouldn't this be the year
that the buccaneers work out some sort
of a low draft pick trade for julian
edelman and reunite him with tom brady
wouldn't that be wouldn't that be the
next logical move i mean that would be
the guy you would think that would be
next on brady's radar if he could bring
anybody to down there or anything like
that
but
you know that's where i look at the
position i mean it's a valid point but
that you know that scottie miller can be
that guy i would think everything i've
seen from him on film this year and all
of that and the way brady seemed to kind
of you know bring him into the trust
tree as the season went along that they
could make him into that guy for their
offense too so they don't have issues in
the weapons department that's for sure
and as long as they protect brady which
it looks like they're good up there too
their offense is going to be you know a
bastard to deal with next year because
this is just the tip of the iceberg what
we saw i mean they just figured it out
in week 13. you know i mean they're just
getting to go in here so now they're
going to be able to grow
our power running game and play action
pass and all of that off of it and it's
it's suited for brady he's going to be
able to play another year or two we see
he could throw ball he could throw the
ball all over the field as long as you
protect him he will dice you up his arm
is still special and i think that's
what's awesome for the bucks right now
too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports